let's head overseas where there are new
health concerns for Pope Francis today a
spokesperson for the Vatican says the
pope checked into a hospital in Rome
complaining of having trouble breathing
and he's going to need a few days of
treatment there Chris livesay has made
his way to that hospital Chris good
morning the pontiff is 86. they say
there's nothing minor at that age good
morning
Good morning Tony but the Pope's
condition is improving that's according
to the Vatican which says he slept well
through the night and when he woke up
this morning he had breakfast read
several newspapers and resumed working
from right behind me in his hospital
room where those blinds are closed
he was rushed to the hospital prompting
prayer and sympathy from around the
world the pope is ill now so say an
extra prayer for him just yesterday in
Saint Peter's square at his General
audience the pontiff appeared in good
health until it was over climbing aboard
the popemobile wincing in pain it's
become a common sight ever since he tore
a knee ligament last year the pontiff is
often confined to a wheelchair when he
does walk he suffers a bad limb forcing
him to cancel both Vatican celebrations
and overseas trips here at the Gemelli
Hospital in Rome the faithful keep vigil
much as they did in 2021 when he was
hospitalized for 10 days for surprise
colon surgery it was diverticulitis a
painful condition that Pope Francis
revealed in January has returned all of
it generating persistent rumors that
Francis like his predecessor Benedict
might resign now 10 years into his
papacy CBS Vatican consultant Father
Anthony figueredo recently told us how
much more time does Francis have to
carry out the rest of his agenda he has
certainly made it clear unless he's
impeded from being a pope maybe through
some mind difficulties through some
illness off the mind he will continue to
be that Pope earlier this year he became
the first pontiff in modern history to
preside over the funeral of his
predecessor Francis championed that
pontiff's brave decision to retire when
Benedict Was 85.
Francis is 86.
remember Pope Francis is already missing
part of a lung from an infection as a
Young Man Sunday is Palm Sunday marking
the beginning of Holy Week through
Easter it is the busiest time of the
year for the Catholic church and now
it's unknown at Pope Francis will
celebrate it from Saint Peter's square
or here in his hospital bed Nate
Chris let's say in Rome thank you